-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
After meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin
on Tuesday, President Biden
said yesterday that he was,
"Straightforward but polite"
with Putin,
and Putin was "as warm as ever."
Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Breathes deeply ]
During a radio interview
yesterday,
former President Trump
referred to President Biden's
Build Back Better plan as,
"Build Back Worse,"
in case you were wondering
what he's been working on
these past 11 months.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
"Build Back Better"...
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my --
I think I got it."
[ Laughter ]
Mel?!
Mel!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke today
with Ukrainian president
Volodymyr Zelensky
amid a Russian military buildup
on the Ukraine border
and informed him that while he
cannot send troops,
he will send a little support.
[ Laughter ]
In his new book, ex-White House
chief of staff Mark Meadows
writes that former president
Trump was mortified
after the Capitol attack
and worried
about his media coverage.
Was he mortified?
Donald Trump?
That guy can't be embarrassed.
He wasn't embarrassed
after this, or...
[ Laughter ]
Or after this.
Or even after this.
[ Laughter ]
This is the same guy
who thought Tim Cook's name
was "Tim Apple"
because he worked for Apple.
If you don't step down
after that,
you're just not someone
who gets embarrassed.
Actually, you know what?
I haven't seen that in a minute.
Can we throw it up?
-I mean, you've really
put a big investment
in our country.
We appreciate it very much,
Tim Apple.
[ Laughter ]
-A Las Vegas money manager
is reportedly proposing plans
to build a casino
in New York City,
or if you really
want to gamble in New York City,
touch a subway pole.
[ Laughter ]
The head of Instagram testified
yesterday before Congress
but only after an hour
of explaining what it was
to Chuck Grassley.
[ As Chuck Grassley ]
"Do you -- Do you have to have
one of them cordless phone
for it?"
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Miller Lite
recently began offering
drinkable Christmas ornaments.
Oh, they're drinkable?
What's inside them, Heineken?
[ Laughter ]
And finally --
And finally, Google released
its annual so-called
"Year in Search" list yesterday,
and the second-most searched
"how to be" phrase was
"how to be more attractive,"
whereas the third-most searched
was "how to be happy alone."
And it's kind of fun to see
people give up in real time.
[ Laughter ]
"'How to be more attractive.'
Oh, a lot of steps."
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
Oh, man, oh, man.